bonsoir et bienvenue dans cette nouvelle
édition du 7 8 ce soir on évoquera tout
d'abord le sport scolaire
alors faut-il le développés où cela est
il déjà suffisant nous en parlerons dans
quelques instants avec nous inviter en
tout cas une manifestation s'est
déroulée aujourd'hui même à versailles
très suivi par les médias il y avait
même deux ministres alors johan blondel
c'était pas mal abonnements nous on est
très satisfaits puisque on avait donc là
la ministre des sports à lire du fonio
et aida ministre délégué en charge de la
réussite éducative
madame george pau-langevin c'était pour
nous un grand honneur de pouvoir
recevoir deux ministres plus la
présidence de la république puisque le
conseiller sport du plaisir étaient
présents donc
avec des ambassadeurs de prestige autour
de nous c'était déjà en soit une grande
réussite d'avoir ce plateau de
manifestants espérés comment vous
arrivez à attirer autant de monde puis
on parlera du rôle d ambassadeur du rôle
de winne et saas avec nos invités
également dans ce set 8 comme tous les
mercredis une page culture présentée par
johanna soudry johanna qui revient ce
soir sur le travail mené par le cahors
le chorégraphe jean claude gallotta au
prisme à elle en cours dans cette
émission parlera également de radio
amateur à ne pas confondre avec les
cibistes et bien jean pierre meriaux du
radio club amateur de saint quentin nous
expliquera la différence et bien
d'autres choses et puis nous finirons ce
set 8 avec une page politique hier soir
sur le plateau de tf1 jean louis borloo
a annoncé la création de l'udi pour
rassembler les parties santis centriste
est ce que cela est réalisable bien nous
poserons la question à erwan le gall qui
lui veut relancer le parti radical à
maurepas mais tout d'abord ce qu'il faut
retenir dans l'actualité locale de ce
mercredi 19 septembre le développement
du sport scolaire je viens de vous en
parler deux ministres des sportifs
reconnus à versailles ce mercredi pour
donc promouvoir le sport dans les écoles
en france plus de 2 millions nidal aides
sont licenciés et puis à l'occasion des
journées du patrimoine une visite a
particulièrement retenu l'attention il
ne s'agissait pas d'un équipement
culturel mais d'un chantier celui du
vélodrome l'office de tourisme de saint
quentin propose des balades du site et
elle s'affiche complet jusqu'au mois de
novembre
voilà aujourd'hui vous surfer sur le net
de n'importe quel endroit via la wii fit
et bien imaginez demain que ces données
ne soient plus véhiculées par des ondes
électro est magnifique mais par la
lumière des chercheurs de l'université
de versailles saint quentin ont imaginé
ce système et de grandes entreprises se
sont d'ores et déjà montrés intéressés
et puis je vous en parlais le
chorégraphe jean claude gallotta mène
des ateliers artistiques au prisme et
long cours nous avons suivi le travail
qui poursuit avec des particuliers avant
la restitution finale ce sera le 6
octobre à l'occasion de la nuit blanche
voilà
on revient sur l'événement de cette
journée je voulais dit c'est la
troisième journée nationale du sport
scolaire pour en parler avec nous trois
invités en plateau yann candele on vous
a déjà entendez vous êtes le directeur
national unss adjoint lainesse sc
triscos bonsoir vous êtes le directeur
régional et eric micoud vous êtes
ambassadeur et ancien basketteur de haut
niveau mais les deux équipes n'ont pas
ce qu'attend de haut niveau nancy
enfin en tout cas où vous avez joué en
équipe de france et puis anthony rech
aussi notre jeunesse aux sports qui est
en plateau avec nous puisque vous avez
suivi cette journée nationale s'était
inversée aujourd'hui mais d'abord une
première question à eric micoud est ce
que vous avez commencé le basket au sein
de bss en tout cas au sein des sports
scolaires
en partie j'ai commencé très tôt dans un
club comme la plupart
des jeunes par contre dans la continuité
j'ai continué à jouer au basket avec mon
équipe du collège mon équipe du lycée
ensuite et c'est là que j'ai donc
intégré l'une et c'est ce que j'ai
commencé à jouer les compétitions qui
était très intéressante parce qu'elle
nous permettait de
défendre d'être fier de défendre notre
collège notre lycée contre contre les
autres institutions et en même temps de
voyager un peu de maisons y ait pu
rester en association mais c'était plus
pratique d'aller en sport scolaire on
s'aperçoit de mercredi après midi avec
les copains ouais alors cessé
complètement différent en club on reste
bon avec en général des gens des gens du
village j'ai une petite ville donc on
les voit tout le temps alors après les
voir à l'entraînement c'est c'est pas
mal mais le fait de pouvoir avec le nss
être avec d'autres élèves qui viennent
de deux villes aux alentours dans des
clubs que le conte qui en joue pendant
les week-ends c'est aussi une super
expérience
ça amène vers le milieu professionnel
vous avez parlé de compétition une
compétition en tout cas ça
ça permet de s'ouvrir c'est la première
ça permet de s'ouvrir et de rencontrer
d'autres jeunes pas forcément ceux qui
habitent à côté mais d'aller un peu plus
en confiance et une ouverture effective
anthony vous étiez vous avez suivi cette
troisième journée nationale c'était à
versailles dans un cadre prestigieux et
en plus il y avait des gens prestigieux
parce qu'il ya quand même eu deux
ministres ouais ils sont devenus et puis
des sportifs de très haut niveau oui
tout à fait il y avait du beau monde que
ce soit du côté des journalistes nos
collègues que du côté personnalité
publique vous l'avez vous l'avez
souligné madame fourneyron ministre des
sports vallières fourniront ou george
pau-langevin ministre délégué à la
réussite éducative qui était aussi très
bien accompagné des ambassadeurs de
l'urss comme jean marc mormeck ou
clément lefert et emilie fer qui sont
tous les deux médaillés aux derniers jo
et justement je voulais vous poser une
question quel est le rôle précis des
ambassadeurs de l'unicef nous on a
souhaité constituer un collège des
ambassadeurs qui est présidée par muriel
hurtis et nikola karabatic et ensuite
cdc s'est pas séparé et ensuite
d'essayer d'avoir un ou plusieurs
ambassadeurs par sport et l'idée c'est
d'avoir des sportifs de haut niveau qui
ont commencé à l'urss ou qui ont
participé activement iss et la bns
espérance qui vient de dire eric micoud
et qui ont un impact auprès de nos
jeunes et qu'ils peuvent passer un
message clair en lien avec sport école
valeur et donc ce ce ce collège des
ambassadeurs permet véritablement aux
jeunes d'avoir une identification assez
facile auprès de sportifs qui par
ailleurs ont eu et ont toujours un
investissement important drapant d evo
et rythmiques ans qu'est ce qui vous a
plu dans l'idée de devenir ambassadeur
de l'unicef quand on vous l'a proposé le
nez c'est vraiment une une partie ça
peut-être suscité en moi
une vocation la vocation de continuer à
jouer au basket après après à partir
d'un moment du moment où on on arrive à
un certain niveau et qu'on est sur le
point de devenir professionnel là là ça
devient compliqué mais j'ai toujours
aimé cette cette association à études et
tu le plus longtemps possible et pouvoir
pratiquer pratiquer le sport qu'on aime
en même temps vous aviez peut-être aussi
rendre un petit peu ce qu'on vous avait
donné l époque où vous étiez à l'urss
oui alors lieu naissait soient apportées
je veux dire dans les victoires dans les
défaites
des amis de toujours que j'ai encore
encore maintenant et c'est vrai que même
si ma carrière après partie sur le sur
le côté professionnel je dois quand même
beaucoup à ces compétitions on prenait
le bus scolaire et on traversait toute
la france pour aller jouer une finale
voilà contre pour certains des joueurs
qui sont après devenu professionnel
aussi donc
c'est moi c'est une super expérience et
ce côté études est plus qu'important et
le rôle des us des ambassadeurs a lieu
les 16 c'est aussi de parler de cet
aspect pour ceux qui arrivent après
carrière et que la voix la verte la voie
est ouverte que l'on peut faire du sport
mais qu'il faut continuer c'est pas
penser qu'au sport au final non surtout
pas surtout parce qu'après ça après
c'est compliqué ça vous fait rêver quand
même les ambassadeurs ils sont là pour
faire rêver tous les noms les donc vous
nous donner ces quand même trop de gens
vont marquer l'histoire du sport on a vu
l'attrait des ambassadeurs aujourd'hui
auprès des jeunes je dire jean marc
mormeck à qui on demandait des
autographes même le conseiller sport du
président de la république qui a été
champion olympique a été reconnue par
les élèves assez vite et on lui a
demandé des autographes à la gare il ya
une
cc c'est normal qu'il ya une empathie de
s'approcher de ces deux de ses
personnages ce qui est très important
c'est que c'est que ces ambassadeurs la
porte un message autour des valeurs
autour de l'éducation qui est aussi très
audible entre guillemets au delà de ce
que peut dire un enseignant et un
un encadrant de l'urss que donc c'est
important que le message aussi viennent
de d'athlètes qui font rêver c'est vrai
c'est clair que tu sais d'ailleurs c'est
d'ailleurs étonnant le nombre de gens de
super sportive de très très haut niveau
qui sont passés par l'urss
dans le basket bon j'en ai discuté avec
un endos de colo qui va partir aux san
antonio spurs cette année nicolas batum
qui dès que je vais parler de lui on
essaie c'est à dire la gt j'ai fait une
finale de championnat du monde j'étais
blessé mais voilà c'est c'est pour tous
ces athlètes super athlète c'est une
partie importante de leur carrière alors
on va continuer à parler des valeurs de
éducative de lunesse ac puis vous
continuerez à nous faire à nous faire
rêver mais on va d'abord aller à
versailles on va regarder le reportage
que vous avez tourné aujourd'hui même
anthony donc sur cette troisième journée
nationale de l'urss le sport scolaire
on dit souvent que le sport est à la
base de tous à travers les valeurs de
solidarité et de respect les jeunes se
découvre accompagné de jean marc mormeck
exemple très courtisés de réussite
sportive la ministre des sports valérie
fourneyron a visité les ateliers au
château de versailles pour la troisième
journée du sport scolaire au sein des
associations sportives les élèves
découvrent de nombreuses disciplines et
acceptent parfois au haut niveau ça leur
permet de se former en tant que citoyen
et puis ensuite ce sont vraiment des
élèves qui du coup ne s'investissent
dans tout à la fois la réparation du
bateau le respect du matériel respect du
cadre et c'est vraiment intéressant pour
certains d'entre eux ont déjà acquis un
excellent niveau ils ont déjà participé
au championnat de france à plusieurs
reprises en slalom en course en ligne
via les gens mal intentionnés cesse et
aussi au niveau des championnats de
france fait le sport c'est aussi le
moyen pour les jeunes en difficulté
scolaire de ne pas décrocher pour
certains jeunes qui sont mal dans leur
peau et bien réussir dans le domaine du
sport que leur permettre de ré accroché
sur un certain nombre de disciplines on
peut par le sport on veut parfois aussi
par la culture par la musique avoir le
déclic qui fait que le jeune se retrouve
bien à l'école et retrouvent le goût de
l'apprentissage mais sont les
professeurs de ps l'urss et des
associations sportives au sein des
collèges et lycées ne pourrait pas tenir
debout nous enseignons de ps font ce
magnifique travail et je voudrais les
saluer tous ce magnifique de travail de
permettre d'accompagner chacune et
chacun en fonction de ses capacités de
permettre de découvrir de découvrir la
fois son autonomie son corps et puis si
on en a la possibilité d'aller plus loin
sur cette pratique compétitive depuis
2007 7000 postes de professeurs de ps
ont été créés l'urss et la troisième
fédération sportive de france
oui justement ce qui est un peu
surprenant c'est que l'urss c'est la
troisième fédération sportive de france
peut-être monsieur monsieur vous avez
peut-être des précisions au niveau
régional justement c'est quand même
assez incroyable comme chiffres oui sur
sur l'académie de versailles c'est 80
mille licenciés et sur ces 80 milles des
licenciés on a mon à 60 % de garçons et
40 % de filles donc
on a effectivement un nombre de
licenciés très important c'est ça
représente 700 associations sportives
dans l'académie de versailles
donc à un maillage et une présence très
importante
justement vous parlez des 40 % de filles
ça c'est aussi une grosse grosse
particularité de l'urss c'est qu'il ya
beaucoup de filles qui font du sport à
l'école chose qui n'arrive pas trop dans
les clubs par exemple le foot féminin
c'est très difficile ça faisait ça vient
petit à petit mais à l'école c'est
vraiment incroyable oui et puis
effectivement pas sûr sur cette pratique
féminine 40% de pratiquantes c'est c'est
un pourcentage très important au regard
d'autres fédérations sportives ont
l'idée n'est pas de et pas de s'opposer
à d'autres fédérations mais à l'urss il
y à 7 cette mixité qui est très
importante mixité garçon/fille mixité
sociale aussi donc une identité tout à
fait particulière mais alors qu'est ce
qui fait l'attrait justement l'urss et
la palette de sports qu'on peut
découvrir ou juste voilà on fait du
sport à l'école avec les copains je
pense que c'est effectivement la palette
de sports au niveau régional on a 40 on
propose quarante cinq activités
différentes
donc il ya une diversité complètement
différente il y a une identité aussi qui
est qui est différente et riscle disait
c'est un moment de rencontre un moment
de partage qui les fait aussi dans le
cadre scolaire et qui eux qui est aussi
reconnue dans le cadre scolaire donc à
un moment il y à cette possibilité pour
des élèves d'être reconnue aussi comme
élève d'une autre façon par
l'institution par leur chef
d'établissement par leurs professeurs et
les autres professeurs pas uniquement
leurs professeurs de ps est justement
pas à propos de l'importance du sport à
l'école vous propose d'écouter justement
deux ambassadeurs qui étaient présents
ce matin jean marc mormeck et marc andré
cratère qui nous ont un peu raconté lors
leurs expériences respectives
ça canalise les énergies ça permet à
près de se reconcentrer si on fait du
sport à l'école c'est important de leur
dire que de toute façon le score et sans
faire
c'est mieux de faire du sport que de
fumier ou par ce témoin de faire ça si
le dépassement de soi c'est une certaine
volonté donc en faisant du sport on se
renforce en force la volonté est bien
sûr qu'ils peuvent réussir quoi sa boîte
à poux de pouvoir cette donnée de se
relâcher et de se nourrir d'autres
choses que les études ici quand j'étais
plus jeune j'aimais pas le sport est
malheureusement je trouve qu'avec
beaucoup de regrets maintenant que je
fais du sport j'ai pas pris plus jeune
pour être
jusqu'à peut-être beaucoup plus de ça et
voilà c'est mon gros regret et je
conseille à tous les petits jeunes de
cobo s'est très tôt et l'autre aspect
justement de l'urss c'est quelque chose
qu'on connaît peut-être pas trop en tant
qu en tant que l'on initié c'est l'autre
voie pour aller à l'excellence au niveau
professionnel peut-être que vous pouvez
nous raconter cette expérience là
monsieur on
fait partie l'association entre clubs
clubs et l'urss
permet
une sorte de complément on voit des
choses différentes à l'urss qu'en club
ou css vraiment restreint par contre
après bout d'un moment
malheureusement
obligé de rentrer dans nos structures
moi j'ai suivi un parcours qui se
rapproche un peu l'urss je suis parti
aux états unis donc j'ai déjà l'air et
school là bas niveau collège et après
niveau lycée et ce qui me permettait
d'aller en cours le matin et l'après
midi de faire du sport donc je suis
resté c'est justement pour ça pour
l'urss
m'apporter plein de choses à mettre pied
à l'étrier en ça m'a complètement mis le
pied à l'étrier et puisse vous savez ces
pratiques des fois les dans les familles
c'est compliqué d'envoyer un enfant
d'amener l'enfant dans son club tous les
ans la prise en charge est totale
on à l'école au niveau du tarif est ce
que c'est cher alors là j'ai envie de la
fédération la plus accessible puisque la
moyenne nationale est à moins de 18
euros j'ai envie sert que pour moins de
18 ans pour l'élève pour un non toutes
les activités c'est à dire que c'est la
moyenne nationale de ce que proposent
les associations sportives donc
aujourd'hui pour moins de 18 euros vous
avez une panne elle un panel pardon
d'offres pratique qui est qui est très
intéressant ce qui fait vous avez posé
la question de thaler aussi le succès de
l'ua nécessaire un encadrement de
qualité des enseignants d'éducation
physique ont les remerciera jamais assez
du travail qu'ils ont fourni aujourd'hui
notamment pour moins de 18 euros on
évoque beaucoup en ce moment les
modifications des rythmes scolaires avec
peut-être une formule à la demande c'est
à dire on travaillerait les enfants
travaillaient le matin frais plutôt du
sport l'après midi est ce que vous vous
êtes favorable à ce qui est plus de
sport à l'école sur la formule en tant
que tels que ça soit l'expérimentation
cours le matin sport l'après midi où les
orientations qui auront lieu suite à la
consultation sur la refondation de
l'école lieu naissait sa patte d'avis
sur l'assaut sur la formule par contre
en effet être président c'est vincent
peillon l'éducation nationale je me
force à qui donc par contre nous on
considère qu'en effet faire plus de
sport dans la semaine c'est être en
meilleure santé c'est avoir une
ouverture différentes comme l'a dit eric
micoud et et a donc c'est dans une
certaine mesure réussir mieux à l'école
mais aussi de manière générale dans sa
vie de tous les jours quoi donc l'urss
est favorable au fait qu'ils aient une
vraie réflexion d'ampleur là dessus
alors on va voir si les saint quentinois
la même réflexion que vous puisque nous
sommes allés dans les rues de saint
quentin pour poser justement cette
question faut-il plus développer le
sport à l'école on écoute je pense que
c'est enfin n'a jamais trop de sport
c'est toujours utile surtout que avec
les problèmes de surpoids qui vont
augmenter en france je trouve que c'est
important oui non pas forcément pas
pendant les temps scolaires mais libéré
plus de temps pour eux pour du sport
mais pas forcément dans le cadre de
l'école mont cadré par des
professionnels fans et des gens formés
pour n'est pas forcément le cas de
l'école tout à fait il ya la place dans
l'école si on aménage du temps pour pour
les enfants si on fait de bons emplois
du temps si on si on donne moi de devoir
peut-être ça détend en fait si c'est
l'école primaire le collège ou lycée
parce que l'école primaire c'est du jeu
ça rassemble les enfants le collège
pense qu'il ya trop de sport surtout
quand c'est de la course c'est très
intensifs le sport c'est surtout pour
oublier qu'on est dans les cours ou les
contrôles tout le reste mais c'est aussi
l'éducation donc faut quand même des
notes le lycée encore ok mais le collège
y en a trop donc tout amusant le collège
avait un trou il n'a pas trop au lycée
en tout cas on a entendu le mot et
éducation le sport ça véhicule des
valeurs éducatives je voudrais une
dernière réaction sur l'actualité du
moment la cour des comptes qui vient
d'alerter mise l'éducation nationale
donc vous avez dit vincent peillon c'est
votre président sur le coût excessif du
sport scolaire dans le cas de l'urss
comment vous réagissez ce qu'elle eut
des pistes de réflexion aujourd'hui à
l'occasion de la venue des deux
ministres alors nous aujourd'hui très
clairement sur la question cour des
comptes
manière très générale je considère que
d'avoir un audit sur le fonctionnement
d'une fédération j'ai envie de dire des
tares la fédération de l'éducation
nationale c'est une bonne chose après
vincent peillon a répondu aux rough au
référé qui est public et je pense que sa
réponse est largement suffisante à la
question de la cour des comptes quoi
donc
il dit c'est en fait c'est trop par
rapport au fait que ça ne concerne qu'un
élève sur cinq et c'est déjà beaucoup un
élève sur cinq mois je n'ai pas pour
rôle de commenter la réponse du mist
simplement un élève sur cinq c'est déjà
très important un million vingt mille
licenciés c'est quand même on est la
troisième fédération de france ce n'est
pas ce n'est pas rien 400000 filles qui
viennent chez nous donc après on peut on
peut discuter du coup le ministre là
dessus a très clairement répondu après
il ya des il ya des sujets qui vont
venir avec avec la loi d'orientation et
des décisions ministérielles mais
aujourd'hui n'étaient pas menacés ça
s'est pas montré clairement mais je
crois qu'à chaque fois qu'on a un audit
externe et la cour des comptes je
rappelle est un est un élément d'audit
des financements publics donc ça veut
dire que l'urss là dessus a le soutien
des pouvoirs publics sinon la cour des
comptes ne viendrait pas l'avoir je
considère que c'est une bonne chose
d'avoir un audit externe c'est de toute
manière une bonne chose après on peut
discuter des éléments le ministre a
répondu très clairement là dessus merci
en tout cas vos trois d'être venus en
paix tant merci anthony on va continuer
ce 7,8 on va parler de sport mais d'une
autre manière à l'occasion des journées
du patrimoine il ya un un chantier qui a
particulièrement retenu l'attention cd
celui du vélodrome et nous équipes
étaient sur place
on a retrouvé sous la piste future piste
de bmx ont derrière eux en cause en
pareil toujours dans le cadre de ces
fouilles prévenir on a retrouvé ce qu'on
avait des gars doux de paris je sais pas
si vous savez ce qu'est une gamme c'est
très joli
en fait c'est une décharge les visites
de sites de chantier ont le vent en
poupe à l'occasion des journées du
patrimoine celle du vélodrome en
construction à montigny le bretonneux
ont affiché complet énormément de mains
de plus que ce qu'on espérait on n'est
pas débordé mais on est bien sollicité
et donc on a ce créneau si aujourd'hui
et puis ensuite on a deux samedis par
mois premier et dernier samedi de chaque
mois jusqu'à fin novembre pas c'est
toujours intéressant d'en savoir un
petit peu plus sur sur l'environnement
sur l'histoire de saint quentin et puis
prochainement la construction du
vélodrome j'ai appris sur tout
l'historique sur la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines que j'ignorais
totalement et puis sur son évolution
également jusque là je ne vois que
l'extérieur mais je pense que c'est une
belle architecture qui est que ce soit
ses impressionnantes
si vous êtes intéressé hâtez-vous celle
les visites de novembre sont encore
ouvertes à la réservation
l'inauguration du vélodrome est prévue
en décembre 2013 il accueillera le siège
de la fédération française de cyclisme
une piste de 250 mètres de long et une
piste couverte de bmx